the brand new series 9 and Ultra 2 Apple
watch models are finally here and many
would argue that they got more
meaningful upgrades and changes than the
iPhone 15 Pro including a huge boost to
2 000 nits for the series 9 that matches
the original Ultra which honestly makes
it really confusing to choose the right
Apple watch model to buy especially
since Apple still has the se2 for a
killer price so in this video I'm gonna
stop all the confusion and explain all
the main differences between them to
help you decide which Apple watch to buy
and I'm gonna give you some advice that
you're probably not expecting so without
further Ado let's Jump Right In and
start with the biggest difference
between all three models the materials
and sizes the Apple watch SC starts at
249 and only comes in aluminum in either
midnight Starlight or silver with the
smallest case sizes either 40 or 44
millimeters and for 100 fifty dollars
more you can get the new series nine
which comes in aluminum at the base
price and it gets two extra color
options product red and the brand new
pink is slightly larger 41 and 45
millimeter case sizes however you can
also get the series 9 in stainless steel
in either graphite silver or gold but
you'll have to pay at least seven
hundred dollars for these and the price
continues to go up based on the band
that you like including the brand new
find woven magnetic link for fifty
dollars more and the new modern buckle
for a hundred dollars more and then
finally we have the brand new Apple
watch Ultra 2 which only comes in the
huge 49 millimeter case size and it's
priced at the same 800 no matter which
band you choose which actually makes it
a killer value as I'm going to show you
in just a minute but you can't get any
of the new fine woven bands with the
ultra unless you order them separately
and with that said let's get into the
huge display and glass differences but
first I've got to show you something
brand new from our sponsor vesi you've
probably heard me talking about my
absolute favorite shoes which are 100
waterproof but now vessi has just
released their first ever a hundred
percent waterproof overcast jacket
giving you complete protection against
rain being perfect for fall weather with
its soft fleece lining I absolutely love
how it just fits so comfortably while
completely repelling water just like an
actual plastic raincoat but at the same
time it's incredibly stylish with its
minimalist curved hem and simple relaxed
fit design and just like Bessie's famous
100 waterproof shoes the shell is still
stretchy while being waterproof and wind
resistant and it even comes with zipper
Pockets to keep your keys in Essentials
safe and dry it also comes in a variety
of trendy colors like black lilac purple
Dune beige and Spruce green and you can
order one today by using the link below
to get 15 off your order with the code
Max Tech at checkout now getting back to
the Apple watch display differences the
ultra 2 has the biggest display size and
pixel density being the only one that
features a completely flat sapphire
crystal glass panel that's protected by
the titanium lip compared to the other
models with curved and exposed glass now
I've been wearing the original Ultra for
a full year and let me tell you that
sapphire glass is amazing since I still
don't have a single scratch on the
display and that titanium finish has
held up incredibly well so if you can't
stand scratches on your display I'd
recommend either going for the ultra or
the stainless steel series 9 which comes
with the sapphire crystal glass but at a
price of 700 to 800 dollars I'd
recommend just going going for the ultra
2 because it comes with a completely
unique design that's rounded at first
but then gets flat towards the display
and then on the left side it's got the
customizable action button which is
unique to the ultra while also featuring
this large Crown guard that sticks out
of the side protecting the larger crown
and allowing Apple to put in a battery
that's 83 percent larger than the one in
the bigger 45 millimeter series 9 model
and actually twice as big as the battery
in the 41 millimeter series 9. and that
leads to 36 hours of battery life
exactly double the amount you get with
both the series 9 and the se2 but it
also makes the watch about 35 thicker
than the other two and surprisingly it's
almost two times heavier than the 44
millimeter SE model and about 19 heavier
than the stainless steel series 9. now
this year Apple has greatly boosted the
brightness of the ultra 2 getting up to
a 50 percent brighter outdoors from two
thousand nits to three thousand nits
with the series 9 also got a display
that's improved being twice as bright
from a thousand to two thousand nits
actually matching the original ultra's
brightness which I thought was
definitely bright enough and even better
both the new series 9 and Ultra 2 come
with a new display that can get really
dark down to only one knit with auto
night mode so it won't be as distracting
at night and it's going to help save
battery life the se2 is Left Behind
without that feature and with the old a
thousand nib brightness and it doesn't
get the always on display either which
makes the other two feel more unique and
premium the se2 also doesn't get the
brand new S9 chip that the other two got
this year which gave them a 30 GPU
performance boost also adding new
features like faster on device Siri with
Health Data access us Precision finding
for iPhone and the double tap gesture
which allows you to answer calls and
them bring up the smart stack and more
by simply double tapping your fingers
together on top of that the SC model
doesn't come with Apple's Ultra wideband
chip while the other two new models
actually got an even better upgraded U2
chip this year the SE also doesn't get
features like the blood oxygen sensor
the electrical heart sensor the third
gen Optical heart sensor fast charging
support the temperature sensing feature
which is available on both of the other
models for ovulation tracking or ip6x
dust resistance the new series 9 and
Ultra 2 also got a big upgrade to 64
gigabytes of onboard storage compared to
32 on the SE so there are so many
feature advantages on the more expensive
models the only thing the SC has going
for it is that the cellular model is
only 50 bucks more instead of a hundred
dollars more on the series nine so it's
a killer value especially if you want to
buy an Apple Watch for your kid with
family setup instead of buying them an
expensive iPhone oh and by the way the
ultra 2 gets cellular included in the
800 price because it's all about value
for the money just like the fact that it
has a hundred meters of water resistance
compared to 50 on the other two enabling
recreational diving at up to 40 meters
deep qualifying it as a certified diving
computer with the exclusive Oceanic plus
diving app the depth gauge and water
temperature sensor features it's also
the most durable by far tested to the
810 H military standard so it's great
for those worried about cracking or
damaging your watch while the se2
doesn't even have ip6x dust resistance
like the other two have and it also
comes with a plastic back which can get
easily scratched up compared to ceramic
on the others the ultra 2 also comes
with a dual speaker setup which is 40
louder than on the series 9 with a new
siren feature better microphones and
precision dual frequency GPS and for
eight hundred dollars it's the best bang
for the buck Apple watch model ever
since it gets a massive 36 hours of
battery life compared to 18 on the other
two and it can even go to 72 hours using
low power mode but now with all those
differences out of the way it's time to
get into my personal buyer's advice for
all of you guys out there including some
advice you probably didn't expect from
me if you're not a child getting an
Apple Watch instead of an iPhone I would
100 recommend you at least get the
series 9 Apple watch and skip the SE
completely because that model is just so
far behind in terms of features
performance and more especially since it
lacks the always-on display and I no
longer recommend the se2 at all even if
you're on a budget just seriously try
and save a bit more money now on the
other hand if you're going for the
series 9 and you're considering
upgrading to the stainless steel model
and especially if you want the cellular
version that brings the price up to 700
to 750 bucks depending on the size so
you should 100 upgrade to the ultra 2
instead for just a bit more the ultra 2
is just so much more premium and unique
looking including being so durable that
my original Ultra looks basically brand
new thanks to the rugged titanium design
and the action button is cool and useful
and the battery life upgrade alone is
worth it because I only have to charge
it every couple of days and plus the new
Ultra 2 now has 3 000 nits of brightness
which is just insane the only reason I
wouldn't get the ultra 2 is if you have
a small wrist and you're worried about
it looking massive on your wrist or of
course if you're on a budget and you're
not going for that stainless steel
series 9 model which brings the price
down to around 400 and in that case you
should go for the series 9 which I'm
honestly really liking this year thanks
to the new brightness boost and other
new features so there you guys go
hopefully this guide helps you make the
right choice and if it did go ahead and
subscribe above and definitely check out
the new overcast jacket from vesa using
the link below definitely check out our
ultimate comparison videos thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
foreign